anyway it's a it's a pleasure to
introduce Simon who's going to tell us
about quantum speed-up for a graph
specification cut approximation and
laplacian solving he's a postdoc at
Andrea and CWI and he's gonna tell us
about this joint work with Ronald Wolfe
so um please Simon thank you
and Joe so hi everyone I hope everybody
is doing well doing good so yeah I'm
gonna talk about this joint work which
one of the wolf which I'm very happy
about
it's about quantum speedy but we proof
for the problem of graphs versification
and cut approximation a laplacian
solving alright
feel free like and you mentioned to
interrupt with any time to ask a
question or just put in the chat and
annual for it that to me so be very
happy to you know be interrupted
essentially so unsurprisingly this talk
is about graphs and i'll just make two
claims one is that graphs are nice at
least I think so
grad show up all of computer science
discrete math biology and so on and they
can be used to describe abstract things
like relations networks groups and again
many more now secondly what I want to
make is that sparse graphs are nicer
well you mean by sparse graphs by sparse
graphs I mean graphs that have fewer
edges roughly so go into details of that
now why is that because they take less
space to store you require less time to
process just off bombs on these graphs
it takes less time and an example this
phenomenon is that expander graphs which
are used to model or to approximate
compete press or it'll be much more
interesting than complete graphs X
paragraphs are sparse approximations of
complete graphs all right so this raises
a very actual question we can compress
general graphs to sparse graphs
basically the topic of a subject of a
line of study called graph specification
and just to put something straight
I'll be talking about undirected
weighted graphs try to talk with notes
@v I've said e and no negative weights W
or graphs will have n nodes and edges
where m is at most and choose two
regarding your edge weights I just want
to fix one thing an edge which is not
present can be seen as an edge with
weight zero which means that basically
an edge with a very large weight is kind
of a low cost edge in some sense okay
how do we access this graph we assume
adjacency list access what does that
mean it means that we can query with a
pair I K and we get from this query but
what the graph returns is the Cate
neighbor of node I so in this case this
would be no J so there's some arbitrary
but fixed ordering on the neighbors
every node and according to this
ordering we will see the cake neighbor
all right so graph specification asks
the following questions somewhat more
specifically I given an input Drive G
try to reduce the number of edge of this
graph while preserving certain
interesting quantities okay so we went
out to the graph H which is one a sub
graph of G and to potentially you re
weighted so it means the degree of
freedom that we have is we can take sub
sub sub set of the edges of G and we can
rewire certain edges and now the goal is
to specify G while preserving certain
interesting quantities all right so what
are interesting quantities what do we do
interesting qualities
some examples are extremal cuts of the
graph such as the min cut or max cut
angle values associated to the graph
properties of random walks on the graph
and so on now many of these properties
are captured by what we call the graph
laplacian LG which is a linear algebraic
characterization of the graph so
specifically we define the graph
oppression of a graph G to
- D - a where D is a diagonal matrix
containing the weights the sum of the
weights of the edges leaving node I so
basically the graph would be unweighted
this would just be the degree and a is
the weighted adjacency matrix so at the
entry I J we get W IJ equivalently and
this equivalent formulation should be
somewhat useful for a later purpose in
this talk we can define a graph
laplacian as a weighted sum of edge
laplacian x' where an edge laplacian li
j is defined as the outer product
product of VI minus VJ so basically this
is very sparse matrix there's only four
nonzero entries maybe two ones on the
diagonal and a minus one minus ones on
the IJ of diagonals and so any laplacian
can be expressed as a sum of these kind
of very sparse so it's a weighted sum D
sparse terms and specifically we'll be
interested in quadratic forms in the
laplacian so quadratic form can be
expressed as follows where X is a
n-dimensional vector so n is the number
of nodes we basically take the inner
product of X transpose with LX this
equals by linearity is equal to the
weighted sum of X transpose L IJ X and
it's quite easily follows that is equal
to the basically the weighted to the
weighted sum of the squared differences
of this factor input factor X to get
some feeling of this consider the
following situation where the input
vector X is the indicator vector on some
subset s is equal to 1 for all indices
which are in s and 0 for all indices
which are the complement of s then we
get that this quadratic form reduced is
something which is very nice namely this
quadratic difference will be equal to 1
when IJ crosses the cut whereas it will
be equal to 0 and when it does not write
so in the picture we get that only the
red I just contribute
with value 1 to the some and yours do
not contribute so difficult we get is
that this quadratic form expresses the
value of the cut ass versus compliment
in the graph G alright now as it turns
out this is just one example of the many
things that quadratic forms of the
oppression expressed so we'll be
interested in quadratic front of the
laplacian like we just mentioned but
also in quadratic forms of the
pseudo-inverse of the laplacian which
will be be denoting by out plus G so de
la pasion has a trivial so if the graph
is connected and la pasión has a trivial
kernel which is just the old ones factor
and so a plus G just means the inverse
of the repression so orthogonal on this
on this kernel now it turns out these
quadratic forms basically describe not
only cut values but also egg values
associated the graphs egg values the
laplacian specifically a factor fij
resistance just hitting x and get many
more things so it seems interesting that
we could we try to preserve these
quadratic forms right so we want to
prove certain interesting qualities and
it seems that this correct forms are
kind of a nice notion to try and
preserve and this is exactly what is
done in spectral specification so in
spectral specification again we start
from some input graph g we want to
construct a sponsor graph H by taking a
subset of the edges and reweighing them
so that approximately all quadratic
forms are preserved right so in so the
entire set of quadric forms indexed by
it by all potential n dimensional
vectors x Morse
more specifically we define H to be an
epsilon spectral specifier of G if and
only if the following holds namely the
quadratic form in the laplacian of h
absent approximates the quadratic form
in whiplash analogy for all potential X
right so you want an epsilon
multiplicative error in the
approximation here
equivalently we can express this
condition using the pseudo-inverse so
this kind of demonstrates that if we
preserve all quadratic forms in in the
laplacian will also preserve all
quadratic forms in the Obsidian verse of
that passion and can equivalently
without much details we can form you
this as a PSD ordering so that I'll H of
proximate I'll approximates LG in this
PSD order there is a very nice notion it
seems kind of useful I prefer the main
question is how sparse can we go right
there can we even drop a single edge and
still preserve all these quadratic forms
because we're asking for quite a bit
here and through a long line of work
which started by was started by Carver
in 94 then it was been through carbon 96
she's peeling and hanging off 4 and
buttons few months shrivastava no 8 we
learnt the following first very
non-trivial statement every graph has an
epsilon spectral sparse a fire age with
a number of edges until the end of
epsilon squared so everybody I mean by
Hotel de tilde is basically hiding poly
log factors in the argument okay so
every graph has natural spectrum sparse
afire with a number of edges scaling
approximately as n over epsilon squared
so this is this is very strong because
because if you only care about so it
comes in fact approximations then
basically we can construct the sparse
fire which only has a near linear number
of edges so near linear in the number of
nodes which can be quadratically less
than the number of H in the original
graph and then second variant you'll see
is that this parser can effectively be
found in in time near linear in the size
of the graph right so try to talk I'll
be talking about when I talk about
classical algorithms
near linear and the input size means
nearly linear in the number of edges in
the of the input graph this is a small
side note this last fall by but since
few monastry hostile history she faster
what they actually showed that the tilde
and the size of the sparse four is
actually not needed so actually you only
need
Oh an eruption squared edges it was very
strong and unsurprising result I can I
ask a question
so yes and this is just you don't
introduce new edges in the specification
right you just like delete some entries
and you may be rebate them yes exactly
so what bathrooms FilmOn she must have I
showed is that that the reaction don't
need it tilde here but I'm putting u
tilde because if you want to find this
parse fire in little damn time then if
you at this point we we can only do it
if there's a till okay small remark this
is this entire concept specification
given this result it's only relevant
when epsilon is that most squared and /
M otherwise you're basically ending up
with a graph which is more edges than or
would have more edge than the original
graph which of course wouldn't make much
sense
come on I think that inequality needs to
be reversed
yes yes so sorry about the a so FM
should be at least as large as an a
square root n over N yes okay so you
have these results are they useful they
turn out to be quite useful before an
important building stone of many near
linear classical near linear cut
approximation algorithms for instantly
form a important cornerstone of the new
linear max cut algorithm by error and
kill from 16 and there's a nearly new
min cut - tcats Farscape and so on and
all these are in kind of algebra
algorithms kind of build on this
specification notion
similarly spectral specific age was
introduced by Chun illan tang basically
for their work on a la pasión solving
they proved you know for the following
famous result in a fennec graph with M
edges the corresponding laplacian system
LG x equals B can be approximately
solved in time near linear in the number
of edges this word and the gable price
in 2050 and use picked refresh Pima on
the left side and Shang Wu Tang on the
right side this again had a slew of
applications nearly this gave a new
linear approximation algorithms for
things such as electrical flows max flow
spectral clustering and again many more
things regarding our contribution we
first note that classically the
sneeringly runtime is optimal for most
graph algorithms not all too hard
that basically by search argument
usually to examine all edges in order to
solve a certain problem now the question
that we addressed is can we do better
using a quantum computer right so that
seems like an interesting question
that's exactly what we studied so our
work can be split up in three windows
basically first we prove that there
exists a quantum algorithm that speeds
up classical specification algorithms
namely we can find an epsilon spectral
sparse fire in time square with M n over
epsilon then we prove that we did our
job well and that effectively there is
no better quantum algorithm and finally
we prove a number of applications so we
find Cuong speed-up for range of
problems okay so I'll start off by our
upper bound
maybe this quantum algorithm share some
details about Ron amalgam or first
sketch how classical specification
elegans typically work this is a very
common blueprint of most classical
specification algorithms most on the
road through sampling so basically
probability is associated to every
individual edge and if probabilities
have to interpret it as sort of
individual Bernoulli probabilities what
do you have what do I mean by that in
the second step we're gonna keep every
edge independently with probability P E
and we scale its weight by 1 over P
right so we could trigger a new circuit
really put all P is equal to 1 just keep
all edges and everything would be fine
but of course you want to sparse Phi the
graph so we want that the sum of peas
which is the expected number of edges as
far as the fire is small now why do we
just do it why do we do this weight
rescaling this leap I'm sure that the
expected weight of a single edge in
sparse fire age equals the expected
weight in G and by linearity does
implies that the laplacian which I
mentioned is just a weighted sum of H
sebastian's equals the original passion
so that's fine we fix that but of course
in order to ensure that LH effectively
approximates LG not just an expectation
I will to prove some sort of
concentration right and so what's a way
to to ensure this concentration and this
was shown in very nice paper by human
and Srivastava no.8 you'll see that
luminous figuring all throughout this
talk basically showed that it suffice it
we can we can ensure concentration by
giving a high sampling probability to
edges with a high effective resistance
so in some sense the effects resistance
of an edge is a measure for how
important these edges but of course I
mean what is the effective resistance so
the effective resistance of an H I J is
defined in a sort of electric networks
analogy so what we do is we basically
replace all edges of the graph by unit
resistors so from time to time I'm gonna
assume that the graph is unweighted like
in this case for an unweighted graph we
just replace every edge by a unit
resistor and now we measure what the
resistance is between nodes I and J so
somewhat more intuitively by Ohm's law
this equals the voltage difference that
we have to impose between node I know J
so as to flow a unit current from the I
to J so if I and J are are in some sense
badly connected that we're going to have
to put a lot more voltage to to make a
unit current flow from I to J right so
the following rule of fist applies if
there are many short and parallel path
from I to J will be many short and
disjoint paths from I to J then the
effective distance will be small and you
kind of understand that because because
this edge will be less important than
there are many parallel paths in some
sense so in this example at the red edge
would have a factory distance equal to 1
whereas the black edges we have
effective resistance scaling as 1 over n
right so for a black edge you can simply
see that by taking let's say two nodes
in the left side and then you can see
that apart from this one edge which
connects these two nodes but you can
easily find
approximately n
these join paths of length two
connecting these endpoints and so this
shows that this black Edge has an
effective use which is small and this
indeed justifies our intuition that
these edges on the left on the left or
on the right in within these cliques are
somewhat superfluous or redundant
whereas central edge will be very
important of course we're interested in
algorithms not just statements about
about crafts and and I just so we have
the following question is it possible to
sort of efficient way identify which I
just have high resistance and hands are
important right and this example is kind
of kind of easy to see but in general
this this might not be the case and then
there's this very nice result by quittez
ensue which we used namely cruising suin
in 14 proof that a graph spanner must
contain all high resistance edges so I'm
just you know bring in a new concept
which is kind of you know easy but I
promise at least for a bit this will be
the last concept I introduced so grasp
spanner
what is that grasp spanner is again a
sub graph of G a spar sub graph now with
the tilde and edges the this time it's
not we waited so it's just strictly a
subset of the edges such that all
distances in F where by distance we mean
shortest path distances are stretched by
at most log n so note that if we take a
sub graph I will get the shortest path
distance then this can only increase
right so if you drop edges then the
shortest path might only increase as
well when I ensure is that the distances
don't get stretched by too much so a
distance certain distance in G can be
log n times this distance in F but no
more right so we want to go from Granby
to spar so sub graph F so jet for
instance this red edge in G should have
an alternative path enough which has
length at most log and in this case and
is just 4
and so what they proved is that grass
power must necessarily contain all high
resistance edges so just to give some
intuition about why this is the case and
the proof is not too high it's kind of
elegant but I'll just give the idea for
R equals to 1 so in the graph is
unweighted then if an edge has an
effective resistance equal to 1 then
that means that there are no alternative
paths between the endpoints basically
this is like we saw in this one graph
where the red edge had effect v is equal
to 1 now since there are no alternative
paths between let's say node I and no J
cap apart from this edge we have to keep
this edge in the spanner because there's
no alternative path and so the the
length if we drop this path between I
and J the shortest path would be
infinity right so we'd necessarily have
to keep this edge present in spanner I'm
basically a similar argument applies to
show that all high resistance I just
should be contained inside the class
spanner ok so given this stuff given
this information we can now propose
someone more applied specification
algorithm which is an iterative
specification algorithm so what we can
do is we first construct Hotel R 1 over
epsilon squared spanners and we keep
these edges so just we just collect
enough spanners basically to cover like
all the edges which which are important
all the edges file factory distance and
all I just which are not inside these
banners we can we can feel confident
that they should be less important and
so we can kind of downsample them and so
this is what we do in step 2 like all
the remaining edges we keep each one
individually the probability 1/2 and I'm
double suite basically to ensure key
expected value equals the weight in the
original graph so thinking back about
this the former scheme every associate
pease to the individual edges this
corresponds to setting P equal to 1 for
the spanner edges and ve equal to 1/2
for the other edges and then basically
using results from streamin and river
Sava and could sensu so too hard to
prove that with high probability the
output of this scheme will be in absence
back
sparse afire with I'm over 2 plus or
tell an eruption squared edges right so
a movie 2 because in step 2 basically
down sampling by a factor 2 and there's
this extra overhead which corresponds
from step one right we construct a tilde
1 of epsilon squared spanners and each
pair has size until then so if you
repeat this process a logarithmic number
of times we get an epsilon spectral
sparser of the original graph with
Attila and the reps from square edges so
this was a classical algorithm and this
is basically what we used to find a
quantum speed-up so our quantum
algorithm consists of three components
one is a faster quantum spanner
algorithm then we use and we call it K
independent Oracle and finally we're
sort of magic trick first is quantum
spanner algorithm what's not too hard to
prove is that there is a quantum spanner
algorithm so kwon amalgam which
explicitly constructs expand inside a
graph which has query complexity skiing
with square root MN so by query
complexity I mean the number of quantum
queries that we have to do to the JCC
list of the input graph alright so it's
not too hard to prove that the query
complexity of a quantum spanner Mulligan
is at most query time and basically by
starting off with the classical greedy
spanner algorithm so just show how this
works so the classical greedy spanner
spanner algorithm starts with a an input
graph and an empty spanner and one that
this this graph F is the spanner of the
original graph right so even if it's
empty and what we do is we iterate over
all edges of the original graph and for
every edge we examine whether the course
so the distance of this edge in the
original graph is 1 so in the spanner
the corresponding distance can be at
most log N and so we check this and if
it is not a case then this violates this
condition we have to add this edge ok
and by just checking over all edges no
one can prove that one
we'll be a spanner and to the number of
edge of F will be hotel and then given
this we can propose a quantum Greenspan
algorithm which again starts from
adjacency list access to some input
graph then an empty spanner an empty
graph at first and now we're going to
use Grover's search to search over the
full set of edges of the input graph and
search for an edge that violates this
condition right next we're going to
search for an edge subject in the
current graph which is supposed to be a
spanner the distance is violated the
stretch con this condition is violated
and then when we find such as edge we
have to add it to F and we just keep on
doing that that's not too hard to prove
that we'll find you a tilde and edges of
the spanner and approximately square
diamond queries
now we're of course interest is not an
inquiry complexity but in time
complexity right so so to make a
distinction when I talk about time
complexity I mean the number of let's
say gates that have to be applied and
sort of standard circuit model of
quantum circuit model right so you not
only want the number of queries to be
small but we also want a time complexity
to be small enough to be able to be to
do a bit more work to be to basically
prove this theorem so we'll call it less
easy to learn but I'm going to spare you
of most of the details roughly what we
do is we start from a classical
algorithm by tow-rope and swig from a
one who use solve this greedy algorithm
they propose a more efficient algorithm
which uses shortest path trees and now
we use a quantum algorithm by dear hi
ligament however and malifaux know for
who proved that one can find a quantum
speed-up in a time complexity of
constructing surest path trees so that's
all I'm gonna say about this this proves
that quantumly would actually speed up
the construction of spanners and so we
thought like okay I mean that's not too
hard so we thought we were done no
because now in step one we can just use
this quantum algorithm to construct this
bunch of spanners which you can out do
in time square with a mine over epsilon
square keep these edges
and bounce sample the remaining set of
edges but of course the problem is that
the scheme has an iterative nature so
what does that mean it means that after
one iteration will still laugh with most
of the original edges name will have
approximately I'm over two edges and
since we're aiming for an algorithm
which has a sub linear scaling we cannot
afford to - to explicitly write down
this intermediate graph whereas
classically this of course is not a
problem and so it's not completely clear
how to resolve this issue
right how do we keep track on this
intermediate graph in smaller of M times
when sub linear time so you small
pictured your original graph we exit
through the adjacency list and then
after one iteration we want to kind of
throw away half of the edges and keep
the other half but this graph can no
longer describe so what do we do instead
the idea here is straightforward idea is
to maintain off line a random string of
and choose two bits so this is an
offline random string which you can just
tear it in advance oblivious to do to
the graph so we don't know what the
gravis we just keep this offline random
string which has and choose two bits
it's uniformly random bit string and it
indicates whether a certain hij is
discarded or we do we keep it now note
that there's going to be a bunch of
edges in there which are not actually
present in the graph but we don't care
about that
it's just like an oblivious thing that
we keep offline and so you can just
generate that and then whenever we do a
query again of the form I K we receive
neighbor J what we do is we check with
this offline random string whether this
edge should still be present or not and
I've turned that the suffice ability to
implement our quantum attributes so now
we get the following picture the initial
graph is described by the JCC list after
single iteration we're going to query
both DJs list and this random string and
it's going to tell us which edges are
still present and which which one are no
longer present but of course there's a
very clear problem which is that it
takes time only got N squared to
generate this random bits
string so so so so how do we deal with
that classically it's not too hard to
deal with that because you can always
assume you have access to very long
random bits and without effectively
having it by just whenever you query for
a bit
generating uniformly random bit so this
is called lazy sampling and that's not
too hard but quantumly we cannot do that
because we have this very long random
bit string well you can do is you can do
queries to it in superposition so you
can kind of address all bits in
superposition and we cannot be that lazy
like we can be classical but as it turns
out we can still outsmart this sort of
all-powerful quantum demon namely we
have the following fact and the fall in
fact is a nice consequence of the
polynomial method which was proven by
bills bloom on cliff mosque and the wolf
in 98 so this is a method used to proof
lower bounds on query complex
contemporary complexities a nice
consequence of this method is the
following fact namely a quantum
algorithm that makes only K over 2
queries to a bit string cannot
distinguish here this bit string is
uniformly random or it's only K why's
independent so what do I mean by K why's
independent K wise independent is a
weaker notion than a uniformly random
string so key wise in the parent string
X behaves only uniformly random on
subsets of K bits right whereas the
uniform random string should behave V
from the random any subset but here this
is only the case for a subsets of K bits
and there's a significantly weaker
notion to show why this is a weaker
notion we basically we can use some some
sort of results here so so so too we
face we aim for a quantum algorithm
which makes a sub linear number of
queries namely square root MN something
like that and by this result of the by
this polynomial method and this fact we
know that it suffices to use K why is
independent random bit string where
skills a scrotum man but of course we
still cannot effectively explicitly
generate the string right because still
it's a string with and choose to bet so
approximately an squared but we only
need to be able to query it and so as it
turns out it's possible to simulate
query see such a string without
explicitly generating it and that's only
possible because the string is not
uniformly random but only KY is
independent name you can use the
following result and we're kind of lucky
to have this result because it's not
been around for that long it's result on
efficient K independent hash functions
by Christiaan apart and forum from 50
what they proved is that in
pre-processing time or delegation we so
so at the start we we just do italic a
work we can build the serve database
this Oracle which allows to simulate
queries to K rising append string of of
length and squared and time poly log per
query so Attila 1 per query right so we
can act as if we have this long keywords
independent bit string whereas we don't
so a kind of elementary color corollary
of that is that any K query quantum
algorithm that uses a uniformly random
string so you can see that as a resource
can actually be simulated and time with
tilde K so we'll at most poly log
overhead without this random string so
in our case we get the following new
algorithm then the first we use this for
amalgam to construct these panels this
is just a telegraph from square edges
and so we can just explicitly describe
these edges and keep all of them it so
can explicitly write and down that's
fine we're in step two instead of you
know flipping coins for every of the
remaining edges we just construct this
key independent Oracle where K will be
scaling a square diamond that implicitly
marks the remaining edges right so you
won't explicitly do that but we
implicitly mark them so that whenever we
do a quantum query to know djc they
start a later point we just
simultaneously query this Oracle which
tells us we'd and I just stood present
or not so per eight iterations will have
complexity scaling as square root of n
over epsilon square this gives us the
fall
theorem there is a quantum algorithm
that explicitly constructs an epsilon
spectral sparse fire with a tilde n over
epsilon squared edges in time square
root M and over epsilon squared so there
is one thing that we still owe you
namely there's a square there and there
should be squared there right we
promised the square diamond over epsilon
algorithm and now I'm going to squared
amount of epsilon squared so we sell
only one magic trick which somehow
remind us a bit of a borrowing from
munchausen shown in this picture had to
you know save himself by pulling him him
up by his own hair so what we do is to
improve the epsilon dependency with
something roughly which looks as follows
first we create a rough spectral sparse
right for constant up phones let's see
epsilon equal to 110 so that's ones
constants will run so the runtime of
this is just square root MN using our
quantum algorithm then we now we have
the sparse graph H what we can do is we
can estimate the effective resistances
of edges and of node pairs inside H and
since H is so sparse we can actually do
that using the Spearman thank classical
solver so so we have access to these
effective resistances and since H is a
spectral specifier of G these effect
resistances will approximate the effect
resistances of G so we get estimates on
the effective resistance is in G using
this rough spectral sparse fine now
these are only constant factor
approximation but as it turns out this
is sufficient to mark which edges we
should keep and which edges we should
not keep basically this constant factor
approximation just results in a constant
factor overhead in our sample process so
we don't see that and so what we can do
is that we can use grover search to find
among these M edges the Anna reps on
squared edges which we implicitly mark
using the effective resistances
approximations so this we can do in
square root MN over epsilon squared
giving us this final and main theorem
which is that there is a quantum
algorithm that explicitly constructs an
abstract
sparsa fire with an eruption squared
edges approximately in time skiing a
square root MN / absolute again a small
side note as I mentioned before spectral
specification is only useful or
meaningful when epsilon is at least
square root n over m and so they
basically proves that this here is at
most a tilde M so it's always faster
than than the classical algorithm and
for constant epsilon and then scratch we
get a speed up from and squared - n to
the three hats basically so I think that
this is a good point maybe take a brief
second and see if there's any questions
so far maybe just how do you use this
dislike rap effective resistance
information to you somehow prepare a
state which is like approximately
proportional twists distances and then
somehow find unit or what's the idea not
quite so basically we know that the P is
individual semi probabilities have to be
at least something like scaling as re
the effective resistance and so what we
can do is we can simulate an extra
register a coin toss which is basically
Bernoulli random variable which so
basically we generate a superposition
over the set of edges for every edge we
have a second register which contains
the approximation of the effective
resistance corresponding to that edge so
this indicates really H is important or
not and then we just add a last register
in which we kind of flip a coin which
will be one with large probability if
this is large and otherwise will be
small and now we just do a Grover search
over this last register
do they make sense
the right does it why is it important
that you know this effective resistance
is here because because first you want
to and so we kind of just sample right
we need to know what we need appropriate
sampling probabilities of the individual
edges and these effective resistances
tell us which edges are more important
and so which I just should get a higher
sampling probability and which ones
should get a lower sample probability
okay thanks there's another question
from chun-hyang Latonya do you want to
just unmute and ask your question or do
you want me to relay it I sure I can ask
I have a question about epsilon
dependence here I think your slide now
you mentioned that a spearmint tongue
the classical paper can do like a sheer
level of M which has full of our
dependence so how do you like explain
the concept more excellent dependency
okay so that's a very good question so
one thing is that this epsilon
dependence here is necessary and it's
also present classically so classically
constructing an epsilon spectral sparse
file takes time M plus n over epsilon
squared and so does that from
dependencies polynomial apps on
dependency is necessary but what I
mentioned before is their result on a
brush and solving right and so if you
want to solve a laplacian system then
you can get a log epsilon dependency on
the error and that's basically by being
a bit smarter so they use this rough
absalom spectral Spotify and then they
do sort of iterative refinement using
this rough rough sparse afire
I seek I observe the same phenomena if
you use a quantum laplacian solver
that's not a little clear it's a bit but
I will go into some details of quantum
of blush and solving a bit later so
maybe that will answer your question
I see Thanks all right any other
questions right now
okay maybe we can save more for later
okay so let me just go to my again so
assuming absolutely squared and in for M
this is at most Attila
so what we do is in the second part of
our work we prove a matching lower bound
and so in the interest of time I'm not
gonna go to all the details but but I'll
first give some intuition of this lower
boundary proof which doesn't do as much
justice however so the intuition for the
lower bound is that quantumly finding k
marked elements among capital m elements
takes time
omega square with m k so this is
basically by using growing research and
this is optimal hence I'm gonna put it
between quotes finding the an eruption
squared edges of sparse fire among the M
edges of an input graph should take time
squared I went over epsilon right but of
course I'm putting the hands between
quotes because it turns out to be not
quite as easy to prove maybe we need a
couple of results but it was a fun thing
so one of the things that we need is so
so the idea here below the hands is that
we want to construct a graph which is
which is a sparse affair and hide it in
a much larger graph of course I mean
what is a specified right which graph is
a sparse afire so to kind of consolidate
what do you mean by that we construct
what is called a unspecified graph so we
start from a small random bipartite
graph on just 1 over epsilon squared
nodes where every node on the left side
is connected to a random half of the
nodes on the right side now we take
epsilon squared and copies of that right
independent copy so we get a larger
random graph which has n nodes and
another epsilon squared edges and now we
can use the following result which was
proven in 16 by undoing each n
crowd grammar Ken Woodruff and John they
proved that any epsilon spectral
specifier of this random graph must
contain a constant fraction of its edges
so basically the graph cannot be further
specified so they prove that so the
reason why they put
they wanted to prove a space lower bound
on spectral specification this result
basically shows that Mapstone spectral
sparse file the worst case requires a
near absence crab edges so they did they
prove this result to prove a lower bound
on space complexity we use it in a
slightly different way what we do is we
start from this graph which we know is
is is a sparse firing itself and we hide
it in a much larger graph right so given
parameters and ma the epsilon we
construct this random graph which has an
eruption squared n nodes and a new verb
from square edges I we hide in a larger
graph which is M edges but all the edges
that we add are just kind of obfuscating
edges so given weight 0 and the original
edges in the sparse file H we give we'd
1 this basically ensures that an add any
epsilon spectral specifier of the larger
graph G should necessarily contain an
absolute spectral specifier of the
embedded graph H and by this former
result by undoing itaú a sponsor of H
necessary contain a constant fraction of
the edges of H hence a spectral
specification algorithm on this graph
should find a constant fraction of the
edges of H which we hid among a large
number of edges so how do we prove a
lower bound on that so basically the
original graph is described by some
bipartite adjacency matrix like this and
the larger graph is described by an
adjacency matrix which looks like that
so basically every entry of the original
graph is hidden among a number of non
significant edges right and we have if
you don't want to check whether one edge
is present we basically have to go
through all these input bits so you can
use column to speed that up a bit
but not too much and then we can forget
about grab and just think about
following more elementary problem we got
an input graph H a which is a boolean
matrix and this a is not given to us
directly but is given to us as the block
wise or function of much larger matrix
where this would be
JCC matrix of the bigger graph and the
task is to output a constant fraction of
the 1 bits given access to this larger
capital n by x little and square matrix
so this is what we call a relational
problem it's a relational problem
because we can output there's a number
of outputs which are fine right we just
want to find a constant fraction of the
1 bits of a but it's composed with the
or function and composing problems often
allows for a nice quantum lower bounds
but it's not always that clear priori
namely what is the quantum lower bound
for in this case the composition of a
relational problem with the oral
function so tonight this result was not
out there and so we asked some experts
name we asked Alexander Bala and Charlie
and upon our question they agreed that
this was not currently around but we're
so kind to prove it for us so this in
the future and it to be published
manuscript they prove the following
thing the quantum query complexity of an
efficiently verifiable relation
relational problem where efficiently
verifiable just a technical condition
which has a lower bound L composed with
the or function which quantity has a
lower bound square root n is a product
of both Francis so so this is before we
would expect but that doesn't make it
easy to prove it but that's exactly what
they did and in our case we can prove a
lower bound of Omega tilde and on the
relational problem and capital n in our
case is M over and ad from squared and
combining these things entering
everything together
proves us that the quantum query
complexity of explicitly are putting an
optional spectral sparse fire of the
graph which is n nodes and edges as
Omega tilde square root MN over Epsilon
so basically proves that our algorithm
is optimal up to log up to poly log
factors
okay so given that we have this
algorithm I will now want to kind of
demonstrate you know what it's capable
of what we can do with this algorithm so
not so surprisingly similarly to how
classically special specifications
really allows for so many algorithms and
speed ups and so on a quantum leap
quantum in the quantum case we find same
thing we have this general blueprint of
the quantum speed-up so that we show and
there's somewhat vanilla namely consider
an input graph G and we're interested in
C approximating a certain quantity
associated this graph P it could be a
min cut this could be southern
Appalachian systems associated is graph
like that and assume that it's
approximately preserved under
specification then also assume that you
have a classical near linear time
algorithm for approximating or exactly
calculating this quantity then we can do
the following thing maybe we can use a
quantum algorithm to specify the graph G
to sparse fair H in time square diamond
over epsilon where H is now much sparser
graph namely H just has added wraps on
squared edges and so you can just use
the classical algorithm on H and solve
the problem on the sparse red graph
right and since this one only has n of
reps on screen edges the classical
algorithm will only take time with a
line of action squared this gives us a
proximate or tilde square root amount of
reps on quantum algorithm for estimating
this graph quantity P a demonstration
consider French the problem of finding
the min cut so if you're given an input
graph G we can which can be weighted we
want to find a buyer partition SS
complement that minimizes the cut value
right so the number of the sum of the
weights of the edges that we have to cut
classically there is a min cut algorithm
by Karger which is near linear from two
thousand videos already show that we
have the two properties that we need
namely the main cut is approximately
preserved by specification and we have
in classical here in your time algorithm
so that proves that okay so the
the approximation part is on this side
and so if we specify g2s parts or graph
H then as we showed the cut value is
just a specific is described by a
quadratic form in the laplacian hands is
approximately preserved by specification
so the main cut of H will be an absent
approximation of the main cut of the
original graph and hence we can just
apply this blueprint scheme may require
unspecified p 2h which takes time
squared I mean over epsilon now we use
the classical min-cut algorithm on H
which takes time and wraps on squared
which gives us a square root I'm gonna
wrap some quantum algorithm for finding
the epsilon min cut similarly we can
prove quantum speedups for finding the
main st card finding the approximate
sparse to scatter battle separator and
finding the Mexica all following the
same blueprint also similarly you can
think about laplacian solving so like I
promised I was going to say something
about this just some background if you
consider a general linear system ax
equals B given a and B and I see that a
has at most M nonzero entries then the
complexity of approximately
approximately solving this linear system
scales as the min of M times n which is
nice for sparse graphs or an to the
power Omega where Omega is a matrix
multiplication coefficient but like I
mentioned before for the Prussian
systems you can do better maybe Superman
thank showed that for a passion al which
has a nonzero entry so basically any
laplacian how can be associated to a
graph and this graph will have at most M
edges the complexity of approximately
solving this linear system laplacian
system is nearly linear in the size of
the system basically then we use the
fact that and this is not entirely
trivial to prove but this is well known
by these people is that if H is a thin
epsilon spectral specifier of G then the
solution of the linear the laplacian
system al h x equals b
absol approximates in some in a certain
or the solution of the original
operation system so that means that
can just solve the linear system in the
sparsa fire and find the approximate
solution of the original system since
the sparse fire is sparser we can do
this faster using a classical solver so
basically we can use a quantum algorithm
just parts if I G to H taking x squared
em n over epsilon and I will solve the
sparser linear system of HX equals b
classically and since LH only has n over
epsilon squared nonzero entries we can
use classically in time Attila and a
virtual squared this guess has a quantum
algorithm for a passion solving in time
but till a square root of n over epsilon
and by a small reduction of the standard
reduction there is a very small
variation on the standard production
there is a quantum reduction which shows
that and this is the same in the
classical case that we can in the same
time solve the more general class of
symmetric and diagonally dominant
systems solar plasma is always symmetric
and diagonally dominant but it turns out
that the much larger class of general
symmetric and diagonally dominant
systems can be reduced to a brush and so
I mean using some quantum routine and so
you can also solve this larger class and
until R squared I meant over epsilon so
this gives us an absolute approximate
solution and times square root MN over
Epsilon a plashing solving and friends I
mean there's many friends having this
condylar plush and solver allows us to
approximate effective resistances in
fact the cover time of random walks
estimating egg values of the graph and
and many more things it is just a couple
of demonstrations and then I'll try to
round up by first giving a summary of
exactly what we did so we prove that
there is a quantum algorithm for
spectral specification which takes time
Attila square diamond over epsilon now
show that this is tied up to poly log
factors and we showed how this gives a
speed-up for things like cut
approximation about passion solving you
know and by some open questions which we
think are very interesting and we're
kind of excited to you know here here
are your thoughts on them the first
question is we prove the matching lower
bound for
versification right so we showed that
you cannot specify a graph faster than
squared I'm gonna absolutely essential
but this is not something that people
are truly interested in what people want
to do is they want to solve min-cut
laplacian system as far as kissing just
a tool for that right so we prove a
lower bound for specification but it
doesn't give a lower bound for the real
interesting applications such as
approximating the min cut or solving of
a passion system so we're very
interested in trying to prove a matching
lower bound freeze applications right so
this would show that friends our
algorithms are tight so it's what is
kind of following this easy blueprint I
mean there's not much more to be done
and it would also basically make our
lower about obsolete because getting a
better bound on Spartacus would give a
better bound for some these problems and
a second open question which I also
think is very interesting is that so
again we proof that our specification
algorithm is type cannot be improved but
it's for a weighted graph so recall that
we very explicitly and crucially relied
on the fact that we can give certain I
just weighed one and then just a whole
bunch of non significant edges where you
can just add so many edges which have
weights here and just obfuscate you know
the axis so you can just not you know
see the cccc you realize which are
important and and we are very strongly
convinced that this little bond does not
apply to unweighted graph so it seems
that for unweighted graphs you know if
there's many edges then typically the
promise becomes easier like I mean that
would mean that things were connected
and so on so so hence the question can
we do better for unweighted graphic
what's the complexity of spectral
specification or solving any of the
aforementioned problems for unweighted
graphs so that was it I'll thank you all
for listening and I hope that you can
all stay safe in these sort of peculiar
types thank you okay
very much so um well maybe I can thank
you on behalf of the the audience and if
you can find this button you can signal
your applause like this and so now we
have time for questions so if anyone has
questions I think you can just feel free
to unmute and ask or if you like you can
you can you know enter questions in the
chat box and I can really
and maybe so not hearing a question
right away maybe I can just start off
with one to kind of break the ice so um
I guess I'm not sure that I understood
completely sort of like the model in
which your algorithms are operating so
like to what extent are you doing this
just in the plane circuit model or do
you need to assume something like
quantum ram you know where you have
coherent access to data that you store
and maybe even modify London so we need
coherent access to data that we store
but we don't need cue Ram in the sense
of being able to generate quantum states
efficiently which which would put data
in superposition or something like that
what we basically need to do is we keep
this offline to a database which marks
edges which is not present or not I mean
to be able to coherently ask questions
to this offline thing yes I see Thanks
are there other questions Oh
someone has their hand up can you hear
me yes please go ahead so for the
applications for the laplacian solving
does the open question that you have
here at the end does that actually
depend at all on the quantum work or can
you just approach that question by just
saying given an epsilon sparse if I'd
graph laplacian or whatever can you know
can you work on the on a lower bound
just given that information independent
of any kind of quantum assumptions so
given a spectral sparse afire I mean I
would say most of the work is done so f2
spectral sparse fire has size n over
epsilon squared and you could you could
solve this this guy in time n over
epsilon squared but I think the main
question is
and now to get to the spectral specifier
does that answer your question I think
oh you I forget now some of this is a
little over my head so you got do you
use a classical algorithm originally to
get the spectral spar sapphire in the
first place and then nope so we use a
quantum algorithm to construct the
spectral spar sapphire and now we use a
classical solver which cannot be
improved on I mean as a classical
algorithm cannot be improved on the
sparser fire
okay so further for the application for
the for the laplacian solving does that
is that just given given a sparsa fide
laplacian is does that give you a better
lower bound or do you need to
specifically worry about how you found
how you found the yes yes yes so the
question mortified so why I think it's
an interesting question is because
spectral specification might have
nothing to do with with with with
solving our passion system so it might
be dead there's an entirely different
way of solving of a passion system using
a quantum computer which might be more
efficient than first constructing the
spectral sparse file and then solving it
you know on the spectral sparse in fire
so I guess that's where the work lies
okay thank you yes sorry I think my
question was look of you I just wanted
to know basically if other people could
be working on that question without all
of your quantum knowledge if you could
just kind of hand if it's possible that
that question just be handed off to
other people and say I can give you this
this sparsa fide laplacian and then
prove that this gives you a better lower
bound for solving the laplacian system
but thank you guys answer my question
yeah I guess not yeah hey um other
questions so yeah I just wanted to say
there was a great talk and I really
enjoyed both content and the
presentation I just wanted to follow up
on what Andrew asked you about this
offline storage I didn't quite
understand what you mean by the you know
why this
storage is offline and y-you can just
consider it part of your so so it so let
me so what I mean by offline is we're
assuming Oracle access to some graph
right so this could be the graph which
is logically described by some function
but it could also just be like a black
box so this is one thing that I would
say these are online queries and but
then offline you know without like
oblivious to the craft we keep this and
choose to size the bit string and what
we need to be able to do is like we can
do quantum queries to this graph we
should be able to do quantum queries to
this offline register and so we need
coherent access to this register which
can have something can square edges and
screen bits okay and I add something to
this please I think the the online
versus offline it distinction is a
little bit confusing it's better to
think of the the algorithm as having two
two different phases the pre-processing
phase and a real algorithm phase and the
the time complexity of both of these
phases is upper bounded by or you're
scared of them and so instead of talking
about offline things I think it's better
to think of a pre-processing phase which
is also not too expensive
yes yes but we need to be able to do
column queries to this this offline
register yes so the the pre-processing
phase sort of produces a classical
memory of about square root of mm bits
and we need to have coherent access to
that memory in the second stage of the
algorithm yes sorry I thought I
understood that that you have these n
squared bits so how do you pre-process
them and reduce them to square root n m
and then for that so so I understood you
have N squared random random bits that
you that here now you need coherent
access to I thought through the
algorithm so how do you pre process them
and okay so we have so many so it's a
good question because it's kind of a
subtle point so naively we would create
this N squared but you know reg of N
squared random bits beforehand but I
would require Omega N squared
pre-processing time I see so this data
structure is exactly exactly which is
requires pre-processing time K where K
would be the independence that we need
and K is just a runtime of Java so
necessary it is that this wouldn't give
an overhead and sorry so what about the
graph itself so you you did need quantum
access to that so how do you reduce that
as well yeah so so we're working in a
Oracle model right in a black box model
where I was fuming that we can do
quantum crisis on graph but of course it
might well be that this graph just has a
concise description right like like in a
sort of physical system and this graph
would have some logical structure and I
we just have to evaluate some function
to see whether an edge is present or not
something like that
thank you okay are there other questions
you have a question please feel free to
just go ahead and ask
okay well I guess if there aren't any
more questions maybe we can thank Simon
again I just want to mention that next
week so in this in this series are going
to be a talk I think again at the same
time they'll be you know an announcement
about it with the with the link if it's
not the same as this week but the talk
next week is going to be by an Oregon
shoe and he's going to talk about his
improved to the area law work with David
Gossett okay so let's let's thank Simon
again and and thank you all for
attending the talk thanks for listening
and thanks for organizing